[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
saison du 7-8
on va parler du prélèvement à la source
alors la réforme du prélèvement de
l'impôt à la source sera appliquée à
compter du 1er janvier prochain
cette mesure va diriger l'entreprise
comme un acteur responsable clé dans la
perception de l'impôt puisqu'elle aura
la responsabilité non seulement de
prélever l'impôt mais aussi de la
reverser au fisc
alors les entreprises sont elles prêtes
ce sera le débat du jour avec nous en
plateau pour en parler béatrice piron
député de la 3e circonscription des
yvelines
je remercie d'être ici et puis olivier
gaudray membre de l'ades eksi qui est
l'association des dirigeants et
entreprises du centre et sud yvelines
c'est parfait bonsoir très bien bonsoir
à tous les deux merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation pour ce débat alors je
vous propose pour commencer de voir ce
que pensent les yvelinois de cette
réforme dans ce micro trottoir
moi je trouve que c'est une bonne mesure
dans la mesure où ça permet d'avoir
directement son salaire sans les impôts
voilà
une vision plus juste de son pouvoir
d'achat moi je trouve que c'est plus
moderne et enfin puis ça permet de
s'adapter plus vite plutôt que d'avoir à
un an de décalage à chaque fois se
compliquer c'est pas une situation qui
me fait peur en soit après j'attends
pour voir un peu si c'est bien ça va
bien se faire si ça va bien être correct
qui aura pas des couacs
c'est surtout ça qui est inquiétant
c'est un peu comme ça que fonctionne
déjà je fais déjà je m'en suis à la
liste déjà avec les impôts donc pour moi
c'est pas un grand changement comme ça
c'est prélevés donc on est tranquille on
cherche pas à payer derrière et de ça
moi je préfère pas qu'on retire
directement sur les fiches de paye
je préfère faire comme maintenant et
font prélèvements à la banque c'est
mieux ça change pas grand chose avec moi
vu que je t'ai déjà
vous imposez déjà par mois donc je
change pas grand chose par an pour moi
simple n'appréhende pas du tout et on
verra puis wrap sait tous et toutes
façons attention il faut le faire donc
voilà on va regarder après on voit là on
a fait la simulation des impôts sur le
site bon bah je sais combien on doit me
prélever et puis c'est quoi après si ça
marche tant mieux ça marche pas comme
tout le monde on nous demandera comme
nous arrange ça est fait c'est quoi
alors des salariés aux avis divergent et
puis surtout des employeurs plutôt
inquiet sur cette question de la mise en
place du prélèvement à la source alors
ma première question s'adresse peut-être
plutôt à vous mais je vous demanderais
aussi votre avis monsieur il reste
quatre mois au gouvernement pour affiner
cette mise en place du prélèvement à la
source ou est-ce qu'on en ait et les
entreprises sont elles prêtes
alors oui il reste quatre mois je pense
que le gouvernement est prêt à justement
on a fait ce dernier check pendant l'été
et on affirmer donc début septembre que
tout était prêt de notre côté du côté du
centre des impôts est aujourd'hui
peut-être que certains entreprises ont
encore quelques démarches à faire je ne
le nie pas et qu'il y a une grosse part
d'angoissé au niveau des entreprises
on parle aussi souvent de l' angoisse
des particuliers mais les envoie sur
votre micro trottoir en fin de compte
que c'est quand même une majorité des
gens qui l'ont accepté qu'ils ont
intégrée qui n'ont pas si peur que ça
donc
certaines personnes auraient préféré ne
rien changer certes pour les entreprises
vont monsieur expliquera peut-être mieux
que moi je pense qu'à des entreprises
que aujourd'hui angoisse encore beaucoup
elles ont commencé où elle commence
juste cette semaine à recevoir des
informations donc à enregistrer pour
pouvoir faire vraiment leur leurs jeux
d'essai pour ceux qui n'étaient pas dans
les jeux d'essai officiel donc dû du
ministère moi je suis confiante quand
même j'ai confiance en français en
général j'ai confiance aux entreprises
des réformes il y en a eu toujours plein
que ce soit des cotisations sociales ou
autres
aujourd'hui les logiciels de paye sont
totalement à même de permettre ce genre
de chansons comme le gouvernement est
confiant tout à créer cette question
monsieur go trêve
outre vous êtes chef d'entreprise vous
aurez quand vous m'avez posé la question
je me suis posé à moi même oui
non non oui oui non et finalement je me
suis dit non pas du tout et je vous dit
en fait pourquoi
non pas du tout pour plusieurs raisons
la première c'est ce n'était pas la
priorité du moment pour nous quel genre
d'entreprise ça c'est une certitude
donc à part du lion c'est pas une
priorité là je raisonne en tant que
dirigeant de pme ou de tpe
je n'y pense pas on entend bien bien sûr
de votre part de tout le monde ils n'y
pensent pas c'est pas top priorité donc
on va voir mais concrètement vous êtes
ça c'est la première propres et c'est à
dire oui mais c'est à dire que c'est on
a tous un grand nombre d'entre nous ont
des cabinets comptables
on se dit c'est leur mission c'est pas
la nôtre bon vous avez un cabinet
comptable où j'ai un cabinet comptable
cela ferait ce cabinet c'est vrai que
j'aurais demandé leur avis non ainsi oui
et non en fait
laurent agouazi sait déjà que les
éditeurs de logiciels soient réellement
prêts parce qu'actuellement ils n'ont
pas absolument pas la certitude
donc ça c'est un vrai problème donc leur
angoisse déjà en tant que professionnel
sur le sujet ça va être de se dire est
ce qu encore une fois on va devoir au
mois de décembre en catastrophe
s'assurer que tout fonctionnera par la
première semaine de janvier
c'est une réelle incertitude et je la
comprends très bien je suis là pour
représenter entre une entreprise donc je
me fais le porte parole à ce niveau là
donc c'est une entreprise cerveau
quelque chose qu'on comprend très bien
ils ont aussi une certaine angoisse y
est ce qu'il va encore y avoir des
modifications
et puis ils ont aussi une certaine honte
ce pas une certaine c'est une réelle
angoisse c'est celle de devoir et pour
nos questions des dirigeants que ceux ci
vont leur poser pour les tpe et tpe à la
fin d'année quand le problème va
réellement à être devenir non plus
quelque chose qui va leur arriver mais
quelque chose qui est là tout à fait
alors là il ya plein de sujets et c'est
vrai que là ça pose un vrai problème
parce que quand vous réfléchissez et
grâce à vous du coup j'ai réfléchi en
profondeur
ce qui ressort en premier lieu c'est le
problème de la responsabilité qu'on nous
transfère alors ça s'en va
vous avez du coup soulever une de mes
questions est ce que les entreprises
sont bien conseillé ce qu'elles sont
suivies dans cette gestion du
prélèvement par le gouvernement alors je
pense que toutes les entreprises ont un
comptable ou que les comptables en
éditeur de logiciels donc les
informations et les moyens les ont
connus il doit ils ont l'information
l'objectif à atteindre les moyens qu'ils
ont leurs dépositions
tout dépend de leurs logiciels mais
depuis 2010 est déjà à la mise en place
de la dsn obligatoire donc la
déclaration sociale nominative toutes
les entreprises tous les logiciels de
paye sont interfacés donc nominativement
donc avec tout ce qui est prélèvements
donc aujourd'hui est déjà des échanges
en direct personnes par personne ce qui
permet par exemple de pré-remplir votre
feuille d'impôts en automatique dans un
dans une grande grande majorité des cas
donc ça va fonctionner dans l'autre sens
les impôts qu'ils vont transmettre un
taux je pense que ça devrait bien se
passer bon je ne suis pas derrière
chaque chef d'entreprise de chaque
comptable il y aura peut-être des écarts
dans les dates de mise à jour de
logiciels mais je pense que la
technologie aujourd'hui il est plutôt
confiant d'accord et justement en cas
d'erreur de l'entreprise
qu'est ce qui se passe à quel moment
tout d'abord l'administration fiscale
s'en rendra compte et qu'il y aura des
sanctions
suite à ces erreurs éventuelles j'irai
cas différents cas il ya déjà les
erreurs qui sont en faveur de la
personne qui n'a pas été suffisamment
prélevés dans ce cas là je pense qu'elle
qu'elle ne signalera rien et puis comme
on s'en rendra compte à la fin de
l'année donc sûrs en attrape âge au
moment de la déclaration finale de
l'année donc ça peut être ça peut être
reportée jusqu'en septembre 2020 un pur
pour certains et pour certains cas si
c'est un prélèvement excessif je pense
que la première personne intéressée va
être le salarié et il va le signer très
vite d'accord c'est certain ce métier
que dans l'autre sens applause un réel
problème parce que
à ce moment là qui va être responsable
de gérer de la perception c'est dire que
vous allez voir votre salarié en disant
vous êtes gentils chers amis on s'est
trompé ou quelqu'un s'est trompé dans
l'histoire mais il faut régulariser
est ce qu'il va dire oui bien sûr a les
idées du témoin 30% de mon salaire pour
le mois prochain
ou est ce qu'il va dire non ça ne s'est
pas libéré il n'est pas question
d'augmenter le taux comme ça parce qu'on
sait dans le président habib hausser le
taux est en fait l'entreprise vous
transférez l'état mais l'état transmet
aux transferts la responsabilité de la
perception de la peau voilà la question
si elle est là donc c'est nous dit le
nom responsable de la version voilà la
responsabilité à présent qu'ils émanent
kick et du coup dans le camp des
entreprises maintenant du prêt avec le
suffixe humaines ou de l'uma dans
l'entreprise sur le derby dames anse et
si c'est l'entreprise qui qui s'est
trompé du tout qui applique un taux
erronée qui n'a pas appliqué le château
ont saisi son parti s'est trompée elle
saisit sans gérer que c'est un petit peu
comme quand
si elle se trompe sur un taux de
cotisation au rrq erronée le roi
d'action et dans ce cas il ya une
sanction et ça nous pose à ceux d'après
ce que l'on a cru comprendre il sanction
une amende c'est donc ce genre
d'information en fait vous ne connaissez
pas je les passais une entreprise qui
est jugée assez paix qui n'a rien à dire
tout de suite c'est à dire priori nous
allons avoir une sanction si on se
trompe dans leur peau du tout plutôt un
nouvel indice qui vraiment à ce qu'il
vient problématique parce que pour être
franc c'est pas notre rôle c'est pas
drôle numéro un on n'est pas là pour ça
donc ça veut dire que clairement ça va
nous prendre du temps du temps se doit
de l'argent
alors soit en temps passé soit en
monnaie sonnante et trébuchante par des
cabinets contact va me dire vous êtes
gentil mais ça nous prend du temps ça a
coûté 20 euros de plus par mois pas plus
d'1 30 euros tout ce que vous voulez
donc ça prend du temps du budget salerno
drôle et bien pour les deux responsables
et chefs d'entreprise se pose toutes les
questions et toutes les inquiétudes du
chef d'entreprise à savoir d'une part la
responsabilité et puis d'autre part vous
en avait parlé
est-ce que ça va avoir un coût pour les
entreprises cette nouvelle prise en
charge est ce que vous l'avez je crois
que le gouvernement a des relents c'est
une somme je crois que les entreprises
surtout commencer une somme ou qui ont
fait une évaluation à peu près à 100
euros 125 euros par an par salarié de
deux coups surtout au niveau de la mise
en place au départ c'est vrai qu'au
départ il faut saisir les taux et qu'il
ya un gros travail là à faire d'ici
janvier ou au démarrage
après non en récurrent je pense que ce
sera exactement comme les autres
prélèvements
pièce ma fille a malheureusement pas
tout à fait parce que vous avez à me
reçoit la mission de tous les mois
s'assurer que les taux sont bien n'ont
pas évolué puisque vous avez une vous
accouchez vous avez un enfant un enfant
une vous allez prévenir vos impôts dans
les 90 jours
le système asmat en place normalement et
vous allez voir modification de votre
taux va bien sauf que c'est à nos
entreprises de s'assurer que le doc ça
ça veut dire que tous les mois ça
devient une mission de l'entreprise
collective a représenté un coût ok
normalement un cabinet comptable dit
demain matin je bougeais de faire ça ça
coûte trop cher alors savourer chef
d'entreprise je vous dis ça va vite et
j'étais ingénieur en informatique
pendant 20 ans donc je pense que
comparer un fichier avec le phishing
mois précédent ça va prendre dix minutes
ou responsables payent pour comparer
pour tous les salariés ça doit ressortir
les trois personnes qui ont un taux
différent il va pas pointer à la main
avec une aide 10 ans 100 salariés ce
qu'ils ont en même temps que moi c'est
dans ces choses qui sont automatisés
donc vous vous serez painchaud
finalement sur une dernière
une dernière question qui n'aurait
vraiment d'un très peu de temps sur la
fin de la confidentialité de la
situation financière du salarié alors
vous avez 20 secondes chacun madame la
députée elle est très claire on a
proposé à tous les salariés de choisir
entre un taux individualisé neutre ou
personnalisés aujourd'hui c'est assez
pour cent des gens qui ont choisi et
c'est tout à fait possible
le taux neutre l'employeur ne reçoit
rien ne sera fait pour ne pas les autos
et comment alors il y reçoit on calcule
en fonction de votre salaire comme si
vous étiez célibataire avec votre salade
à corps entier d'une fonction donc une
sais pas si vous avez des enfants et ses
passes en 7 min vacants alors il nous
reçoit je sais pas si vous avez 10
secondes même pas
ça pose de soucis à la notion qui nous
est imposée de secret professionnel qui
n'est absolument pas normés donc on sait
absolument pas ce que ça veut dire et
qu'on va devoir proposer un nouveau
salarié enfin aux salariés responsables
des salles et crh et 2c nos pauses non
un problème moral - dont on guérit gens
comme vous dites le taux est neutre tout
ce que vous voulez mais je vois quand
même le niveau de vie de la personne et
c'est un souci et en plus ce n'est pas
inscrit dans notre histoire culturelle
ou en france les revenus demeurent
quelque chose nous donner secret de
cacher qu'on nous donne pas entre nous
et voilà ça me pose un souci
bon ben ce sera un mot de la fin de son
malheureusement on n'a pas plus de temps
pour débattre de ce sujet qui
effectivement soulève beaucoup de
questions et d'incertitude alors merci
en tout cas tous les deux d'être venu
pour ce débat ce premier débat ce
premier set 9 prochaine émission
mercredi prochain d'ici là vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission en replay sur
le site tv 78 points comme ou
l'application tv 78 merci à tous bonne
soirée bonsoir
[Musique]